the spoils before dying because this is
such a great idea this is set what would
use the 50s we just say it's the 50s
late 40s it's sort of a noir late 40s
early 50s the world like the underground
world of jazz yes where people are like
very hip and there's a there's a lot of
smoking going on and a lot of a lot of
terminology that people don't use
anymore
right oh it's so beautifully done my
buddies Matt Piedmont Andrew Steele who
are also from SNL did it they did the
spoils of Babylon first yep and this one
is like a whole other era and a whole
other weird wonderful world I got to be
a jazz singer named Fresno foxglove
Fresno foxglove you know what I love
about is that the it's the terminology
you guys have really captured the spirit
of those times and then all that that
crazy early jazz yeah we're all like a
cat everybody's a cat and you dig and
it's just it's it's fantastic and you
guys have a lot of fun with it you have
a lot of fun with playing out everyone's
so intense but they're talking in this
language which we now observe you know
think it's kind of absurd and crazy it
is yeah it is and it's great cuz it's
just like it just specifically stopped
during that era like no one asks anybody
if they did getting more like go clean
your room you dig I feel like if I use
that I'd get taken advantage of a lot as
a mom like oh my mom's were loose yeah
she asked me if I dig all the time yeah
what do you mean do I dig you well
that's funny because even back then
marijuana was I remembered once one of
my uncles you know one of my one of my
uncle's he wasn't he didn't smoke
marijuana or anything but I remembered
him once referring to them when I was a
kid like yeah those those musicians over
there probably smoking those jazz
cigarette
what's a jazz cigarette yeah yeah he's
gonna he said he's probably at he's he's
hoping at Taurus and he said that
guitarist is probably got a jazz
cigarette stuffed down his bootleg oh
you talking about
[Applause]
yes he does we as a family we actually
we keep Turner Classic Movies on yes but
in our kitchen this is actually real
like 24 hours a day so that it will seep
into the children's minds is what you
have how many kids now or if you have
four kids and so you want them you want
them to know all that terminology orb
absorb all those looks and all the
terminology and just like and it's
really funny cuz like you you know
you'll come into the kitchen you know
late to get a snack and so I want to
talk like this you see or like they know
you you're like hearing or like or in
the morning you're we're all in there
you know and everybody's it's by the
toaster the TVs by the toaster so then
you like you hear like I'll be making
breakfast and I look over and my
four-year-old sons just like watching it
and it's like it's like some beautiful
lady talking to somebody it was like a
cigarette and I'm wondering like what is
my son thinking you know like
authorities picking up all this great
this great sort of classic yeah speak
there's I think one of the great movies
of all time for that stuff is sweet
smell of success with Tony Curtis it's a
great movie and there's a line that has
it has it has a million and they play it
on Turner Classic Movies but has a
million great lines in it it's got it's
just packed wasn't but one of my
favorite ones is someone asks Tony
Curtis did you get the job done and he's
and he says to 20 Christians get the job
done and Tony Curtis says the cat's in
the bag and the bags in the river you're
like every now and then my wife will say
to me like did you get those grapefruits
and I'm like the cat's in the bag the
bags and the river she's like I married
idiot
laughter I love that what's your way I'm
married cat drowner jelly cat how my
kids are crying hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please